yeah but there's no either really not
either
so what happened last night you went to
uh lemmy's yeah lemmy's 70th birthday at
the whiskey and was it [ __ ] nuts oh
man invitation only yeah
no invitation only okay now they've done
it 20 years ago on his 50th and
metallica played that one where each guy
in metallica dressed as lemmy and they
were called the lemmies and that was
pretty [ __ ] epic man you can google
it and look at it or youtube it but um
this time
they put together an all-star tons of
guys it was like steve jones sex pistols
billy idol
sebastian bach slash
ian um escottian from anthrax you had
dave lombardo slayer another cuban
um
i mean it was on and on all these guys
and they played all kinds of songs they
opened with some zeppelin they did some
uh just got paid by zz top
um they did some then they learned some
50 songs that lemmy loved and they just
rotated jammers jeff mckagan
uh billy duffy from the cult it was it
wasn't like no sea league this was like
the hitters were out there man but rudy
wasn't there yeah well i was invited but
uh i got the call i was on my way to
family
holiday reunion you know and it's like
the time that you pick people up and
then you got to bring him back and by
the time
you know i was home it was like you know
the trip to fan hit and i was passed out
before we go any further he was saying
something very interesting happy
birthday to you brother yeah yeah yeah
thank you 65 years old
and you're just getting all started yeah
i'm getting [ __ ] up 65 years
you're just getting started when we were
growing up if you heard the number 65
you were like jesus christ i'm [ __ ]
dead
you're going on tour next year you know
it's just amazing what the things you
could do if you take care of yourself
i'm doing senior homes next year [ __ ] it
whatever he looks better than me yes he
does whatever pays the mortgage
and that's amazing it's it's just a
beautiful thing that you're still out
there did you think
that you'd still be out there
at 37. you know what you're going to be
able to confuse you you know i i love
watching crossroads which is uh the
events that eric clapton puts on just
about every year right you know and i
would say everybody every time i watch
the show most of the people are way
older than i am and they're still like
killing it you know they're playing the
blues and they're rocking out you know
and it's like oh my god you look like a
buddy guy he owns the stage every time
he gets up there you know
eric clapton i mean everybody across the
board and i go like yeah i want to do
that man i want to be you know when i'm
that old you know i want to be like
miles davis guy on the road you know
playing you know being a musician this
is what i am how are you just clapping
now
i don't know yeah lee can you look that
up yeah absolutely because lemmy is 70
last night you know or well look at
lemmy yeah was he there last night
drinking [ __ ] he was there was he
drinking yeah he drinks was he smoking
cigarettes i'm sure he's he's never
changed he's not like i'm getting at
this age i better uh slow down you know
he's exact lemmy from like 69 lemmy or
that guy was a roadie for hendricks
yeah
first tour i did with ozzy motorhead was
the opening
band right yeah and i gotta tell you i
let me war on stage and off stage the
same clothes you know it wasn't like
what we have or you know on stage
outfits and then we're going to have
like you know just what i wear you know
in the bus or whatever no it was like
these guys and the whole crew and band
was the same thing you know just like
blue jeans jackets and
jeans and that's it you know you just
you know except that i think he put on
the bullet the bella belt yeah put the
bell when he went on on stage and then
he took it off when he got off the stage
that's about it you know they had a they
had a 10 minute video of like a 15
minute video of his life
which is far too short but as it went
through it started from like early on
when he was like 14
to now and it was unbelievable yeah who
he had played with who he hung with he
was keith emerson's roadie back in the
60s when the he had the band the nice
yeah and he's the one who gave keith
emerson the daggers
to stab the keyboard with so you you
you know about that yeah you know
emerson used to be like right amazon
lincoln yeah yeah well this is before
that
absolutely the night you know they had
that song america
you know on the on the organ and part of
the stick was that he would take these
daggers and just like make chords you
know like like keep chords you know on
and just and then he was solo on top of
that and throw the
organ on you know around the stage and
stuff but it was lemmy who gave him the
they were actually german nazi daggers
he worked for hendricks too right yeah
he did yeah he was hendrix's roadie yeah
you know
insane and then he starts uh he plays in
hawkwin which is like the first early uh
they see what the grateful dead's doing
and they go we want to do that but in a
60s kind of uh london acidity way and
hawk wins like the psychedelic crazy
huge band you know like a huge
underground band did a lot of musicians
get their start being roadies because it
seems like it'd be a great learning
experience yeah like an open mic or you
know i mean i you learn from hanging out
at bands rehearsals and stuff right when
you're a kid
you know you're at a band i was like a
young kid at an older band's vicious
rumors you know that band there they're
like a metal band and i would hang at
their rehearsals and learn [ __ ] you know
well i know like if you're a guitar tech
yeah right you've obviously a guitar
tech you're a badass guitar player
right or wrong oh no not really some
guys learn the uh because you have to
like uh tune in the chords for the guy
whatever the hell it is so you have to
be learning something along the way yeah
i mean there's people in this town
they're coming as comedians and that's
what they do and there's other guys that
end up writing and doing a little bit of
television and you just learn along the
way you become a sort of like a master
of everything you know prince could play
everything you can play a bunch of
[ __ ] instruments can't you i play the
radio right okay you play the [ __ ]
radio
but it's uh lemmy was just one of those
guys that
learned it a the [ __ ] z you can't go
to let me write you go to let me right
now i'm going i'm going on tour can you
come and look at the stage set up and
he'll go there and just point little
things make the curtains blue
make this red just things that you learn
from [ __ ] doing it that somebody
can't tell you yeah but the problem is
you you want to understand what he said
what he's saying right
all right so here you are
uh whatever the [ __ ] uh
the first band and then you move on to
ozzy quite right and quiet ryan then you
go on this tour
that last god knows how long you didn't
you guys didn't even expect that type of
success they did they used to last for a
year and a year
oh yeah and his hit is with lemmy and
motorhead everything well yeah yeah the
aussie well actually the first yeah it
was the first leg of the blizzard of us
tour
and the end of the tour
uh
we went over to england to a place
called
an event a festival called port vale and
this is 1981
and motorhead headlining the black
sabbath with ronnie was supposed to be
the band
that was going to play before motorhead
you know like special guests and they
pulled out for some reason so
motorhead asked aussie hey you guys want
to be the one so we actually we we took
the concord because we had like one day
to do it to go back and play and come
back right
and we did the gig and then we got back
in the concord and got to new york
before we left london
you know we left like eight o'clock in
the morning we got to new york and like
at seven or six you know there's
something ridiculous like the concord
yeah that's rockstar [ __ ] right there no
no rexxarchez watching ozzy peeing
outside
the bathroom because he couldn't get in
the bathroom in the concourse no yeah no
[ __ ] way yeah yeah
oh he pissed on the wall at the concord
yeah
well on on the door of the bathroom yeah
there were like three or four bathrooms
on one side and he couldn't get in which
was
there's aussie pissing oh my god did
anyone see him i did
did i say anything no no
[ __ ] motorhead as our opening band
that's
it was sick
because i remember going to see the at
the palladium show it was motorhead
and going who the [ __ ] are these savages
yeah these guys are saying delicious you
know we they put it this way our bus was
very
clean because you know sharon was trying
to keep ozzie out of out of trouble you
know as best she could so we had nothing
in our bus then you go to moto heads but
there's like
hookers and strippers and blow and vodka
and pizza and
whatever you know piles of people and
all over the bus
oh yeah
amazing
it's funny that's what i think green
rooms are going to be and then anytime i
go in a comedy green room it's probably
more laid back than than your bus with
sharon it's it's like just people like
just sitting like it's a waiting room
that's different scene though different
scene you know
i think now you're
you got to look pretty professional
because you don't want the club owners
to come back and go these guys are just
doing blow and they're all [ __ ] up i
don't want them back you know i was
telling somebody a day that
i don't know anybody who's a comic right
now
that's causing any problems yeah
nobody there's no beside cat williams
you know a couple years ago god dresses
though there was a story about mitch
hedberg every other weekend you know
there's always when i started comedy it
was a couple guys that were still
getting [ __ ] hammered yeah you know
george lopez still had both kidneys that
[ __ ]
was getting [ __ ] up in 99 in 2000 yeah
then what's her name saw him and got him
on the show and but there was a time i
haven't been in miami with george lopez
and going where the [ __ ] is george on
the floor
he was on the floor i'm not making a
joke on the floor wow i had to do radio
for him as a feature act he wouldn't get
up the next day george was the real deal
yeah mitch every two weeks you know
before that you had kennison there's no
crew that was causing havoc yep and last
night you took pictures with duff yeah
red band and i read duff's book yeah you
know and i suppose duff is clean now yep
absolutely and you're clean yeah and
you're clean and uh
everybody in this room is clean from i
mean i smoke pot i love smoking pots i
was a kid i do it just as it's not like
look i went and smoked the whole joint
of [ __ ] that kills most americans
i do it now just out of [ __ ] habit
just as stupidity any day now i'm going
to wake up and think i'm not smoking
there's no more because it don't do
nothing it don't do nothing no more but
it's amazing how your life changes
how at one time you know it was
everywhere it was [ __ ] everywhere
rudy anywhere you turned you on the road
with ozzy and a savages he played with
sam yeah
yeah and that whole [ __ ] scene there
he made ozzie look like a beginner and i
remember that i
i used to
when i you know until until eight years
ago i would go on the road and i'd get
high afterward and yeah from time to
time you pick up a victim
at the club and they suck your dick and
you know you got to throw them out the
next boy
but i couldn't even
like right now even if i wanted to like
sobriety for me from drugs has been easy
because even if i wanted to yeah i
wouldn't do it it's like i don't see the
and you look at all you know i still
remember slashing guns and roses on the
american music award whatever the [ __ ]
you were on that time
on television national television they
were [ __ ] gone yeah they would just
rip that grammy's whatever the [ __ ] it
was that show that one year yeah yeah
american music awards and now people
just move on you know i just saw the
final hours of michael jackson anybody
catch that yeah that documentary that
was great he was [ __ ] getting down
yeah i mean michael jackson said [ __ ] it
i'm wearing a wig jack i need to get i
mean he was [ __ ] putting [ __ ] in his
body we wouldn't dream about
but besides that as musicians i don't
know anybody who's really
drugging it up anymore comics what do we
my green room has nothing has no waters
yeah waters i don't have blood i brought
bananas today bananas to a [ __ ] thing
it's amazing how you evolved you never
thought of that when you were in the
blizzard of oz and a couple bands after
that and sam you would be there like
going when does this [ __ ] end
i was talking about that the other day
would sam still be getting higher you
know you just brought up something
really interesting yes absolutely and i
gotta tell you a bit of it it's uh
uh and this is i'm not saying this is
the way it is but this is an observation
uh
i think that what happens is you know
you
you start getting successful and you
become untouchable you become
unbreakable bulletproof
and then [ __ ] happens and it brings you
right back down to earth you know like
with in my case it was randy randy on
the plane crash
that that's like brought me back to
reality
you know uh
but i think today
and i i'd love to hear your opinion on
this because of social media
i am in direct contact with the fans
the we have lost that putting musicians
on a pedestal
you know mystique it's all like we're
you know
we're all at the same level here
so that be becoming unbreakable
untouchable doesn't really exist anymore
because you become really transparent to
these people they really know i mean
they know what my wife looks like my
little dog you know they see pictures of
my house picture of me hanging out you
know stuff like that the walls are down
the walls are down so that gives you a
little bit more of of uh center you're
more planted rather than to be like
feeling like you're untouchable like
above anybody and i think that's what
happened when people start thinking
you're above everybody that's when you
say i'm well i can take more drugs than
anybody else because i'm above everybody
else look at me i'm successful doing all
the stuff so i mean i'm sure
yeah great as a person but most people
don't pee on plane doors when they have
to wait for a bathroom he's from england
have you ever been to a pub in england
there's more piss on the ground than
there is uh
there's beer on the bar i'm telling you
it has to go somewhere and everybody
misses it
usually they're troughs you walk into
the men's bathroom it's a trough it's
not like these little toilets like we
have yeah at the festivals they actually
have piss walls i've never seen anything
like it in europe so you're at a big
festival say the size of coachella and
you'll just walk up and go what is that
and it's like a hundred foot wall and
dudes are just pissing right there in
front of everyone on a wall yeah
it's crazy yeah and that's the way he
was brought up so if he sees the wall
well he pissed on the alamo come on yeah
you got arrested for that yeah
it was from birmingham which is an
absolute ghetto you know just like you
know the bottom of of europe it's
actually pretty nice now now it is yeah
yeah yeah like i went to sheffield and
you're like okay that's nice did you
ever watch this documentary yeah awesome
you know when he was born he had been
like maybe 10 years since
the war ended this place was dilapidated
it had been bombed by the nazis you know
so you're being brought up and next to
rubble
rubble you know buildings all destroyed
and everything absolutely you know
so
you know so you grew up in an
environment like that and you have
certain you know ethics also
the i think the pressure of being the
rock star gets you to get crazy too well
that's that pressure that i was telling
you you know we're telling you about
yeah you know it's it's it's not even
pressure it's like this is the full
sense of
of being
you're successful and people like uh
yelling at you and chasing you and you
can create this false sense of like uh
wow i'm i'm
i'm like really cool or untouchable or
unbreakable nothing you know and then
you start doing
stupid things
you know but now i think everybody's a
little bit more more grounded grounded
yeah it's it's just yeah
you know in the 70s jesus you heard
about a band every [ __ ] week and
there was no internet no no no there was
no internet and you heard you know
different rumblings and then
you know i
went to in union city pastoral music
and everybody who plays the garden goes
to pastoral music that's just the way it
is you'd see him you know the time i saw
dwayne alderman in the [ __ ] chair
there oh i was like what the [ __ ] is
this and i went in there and i started
taking bass lessons and the guy was
telling me every time these people come
into
new york they come over here they do the
garden they come up with a pastoral
music it's been there for 50 [ __ ]
years yeah yeah and you just heard
rumblings of this and that you don't
even hear that anymore you know drake
these black rappers they don't do
nothing they drink champagne out of a
[ __ ] thing with a straw yeah they got
a bottle of that [ __ ] then they drink
that cough medicine that's big now yeah
yes chris whatever code they don't they
don't i when i went to the doctor they
don't have it anymore at the doctors
because of that the codeine stuff yeah
it's great yeah i've never i've never
had it like what they do and poured into
soda but crazy dreams on that i drank it
you have psychedelic radical dreams on i
couldn't believe it you're like whoa you
wake up like i mean whatever's in there
makes you see monsters
you know when you're sleeping i was
never a coding guy i don't have friends
that were into that [ __ ] but it just
it's not i couldn't imagine
doing what i did 15 years ago and going
on the road now i couldn't [ __ ]
imagine well here's a good example this
is how clean the slate is is how queen
this latest we lost scott weiland last
week
but over the last
two or three or five years or whatever
you would hear rumblings like that he
was still you know like he got a dui on
his birthday hit some cars and stuff he
was like the last really
of the radical rock star you know the
one that was still carrying the flag so
to speak of like hearing stuff right
i mean no i don't know you know that's
you know
growing up i i work with a lot a lot of
musicians who have mental issues
and
i got to tell you rock stars you know
anybody who's labeled a rock star can
get away with anything
get away with anything things that
actors athletes politicians
nobody else can get away with just i
mean just because you're a rock star oh
you know you're a rock star of course
you can do that you know what baffles me
about the rock star is that
they'll never give up
like that's the rock star i love like
you're a rock star rudy sarge i hate to
tell you you're a rock star
you have everything your aura
uh your persona you know whatever that
word a rock star you did it you did it
but there's people who are fake rock
stars but the rock stars today
from that era have not changed the other
day i was scrolling through and i
watched the heavy metal thing
and i saw paul michael shane i think i
called you
poor guy didn't even know what planet he
was on yeah but he's still a rock star
he don't give a [ __ ] he's still got the
blonde hair with the [ __ ] chain
leather jacket he's a [ __ ] rock star
and he'll be you know some people one
day go you know what that's i don't do
this no more as much i do this part-time
i'm changing my wardrobe you know these
guys have held on and you gotta love it
kurt hammett you know
these guys are just uh and i respect
that you know just because you're not in
the war you're still in uniform [ __ ]
yeah yeah you know what i'm saying you
can't be in uni it goes both ways i got
a question for you guys because uh
for me
as soon as i get off the stage i'm
already thinking the next time i'm going
on stage because to me that's right
that's home yeah it's weird i feel more
comfortable on stage than i do crossing
the street
as long as i know what
you know what songs i'm playing you know
if i if okay i got it okay so i just get
up there and do it you know and
and i get lost you know i'm a different
musician with every band that i play you
know with aussie i was different than
quiet riot and white snake and and so on
you know because i just get caught in in
the in the
in the spice that everybody else brings
in you know the flavors you know
everything because
every band is different you know let's
say if i i would be doing blacks have a
song with ozzy i did a whole record you
know
speak of the devil then i did black
sabbath songs with ronnie it's a whole
different black sabbath experience
oh god yeah yeah completely different
it's it's a different element that each
individual brings in the band you know
so you have to feel that you have to be
aware of what everybody's communicating
and and putting out energy-wise you know
and i don't have that in in in my life
you know i have a very normal existence
you know i got my wife of over 31 years
i'm my little dog and i have a home i
got a brother you know
my folks
and
and all of that but is when i get on
stage that's the person that you
probably connect with the guy that you
remember me oh i remember watching you
in a show or a video or whatever you
know that's
that's even more real me
because there's no
there's no gov you know nothing
no no parameters really it's you know
complete freedom yeah complete free
freedom of expression and and being
myself within the parameter of what i'm
doing
again you know
i was i'm different player in in every
band because there's certain parameters
right in every band right
you know like i remember when i joined
white snake i you know being aware of
that i told david you know hey so
what do you want me to do and he said be
yourself
okay
and i think of all the bands i've ever
been in that was the one that i just
went [ __ ] out of my mind on stage
with yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
just do yourself okay that's it yeah
how like when you play now
do you get like brought back to when you
were like 25 or however you were when
you started playing like do you feel
like you are playing now or is it like
you're just like zoomed back you know
that is a really good question and it's
multi-layered my answer to that
uh
i don't know about you guys
but i find that if i do songs
from
that includes past band members
that are not longer with us there's an
element of pain
when i play those songs like when we do
the uh the randy rhodes yeah when we did
that you told me that you said that it
was uh it's it's hard it's hard because
you're on stage and
you're like in you in my mind i'm there
man i'm there like you know i'm there at
whatever gig
picket you know
you know i'm i'm at the garden you know
uh
well randy wasn't there at the garden
but you know what we're doing like any
any gig any gig at the san francisco day
on the green yeah whatever you know it's
i i'm there
i'm there with randy playing those songs
i never forget i don't know okay you
know uh you know if i if i do a quiet
ride you know recently i've been sit you
know
sitting in you know just doing one song
with quiet ride with frankie you know
because we you know gunzo and fly right
we've been doing some shows together
this year and and one one one show where
i got in to do come and feel the noise
and it was like you know i'm playing
with frankie you know come on feel the
noise so of course it's all gonna come
back you know and there's a there's an
element of pain that i think every band
that is a legacy band today that's been
around for over 30 years
they they bring that element
on stage which is different from
watching a tribute band
you know like if you watch an ac dc
tribute band it's not the same
experience that was watching ac dc
because first of all bon scott right
yeah you know i mean
brian johnson great incredible singer
but i'm sure when they do highway to
hell or tnt any of those songs there's
gotta be bon scott on stage with the
guys that were there with him
years ago he comes up he's gotta be in
their brain saying [ __ ]
he's not here somebody else is singing
the songs
you know so you have that element of joy
of celebration of the music you also
have the pain
that your buddy that you had this
amazing journey with it's not there
anymore
yeah that's got to be interesting right
[ __ ] beautiful like you're like we're
playing that randy rhodes thing and you
just
you're playing
this tribute to a guy
like to me
i'm jamming with you at the thing and i
loved uh randy but you played with him
and he was a brother so it's like
responsible for my career exactly so
it's it's got to be really weird i'm up
there like giving a tribute and you it's
a lost brother yeah i mean the same
thing with uh uh when ronnie passed away
you know uh wendy wendy actually
masterminded this uh it's called deal
disciples and i did it for about six
weeks and it was exactly ronnie's band
you know you got scott warren on
keyboards and goldie on guitar and simon
on drums and me the band ronnie's band
but we had two singers tim repper owens
and uh and another singer from from
england and uh
the and as good as the band sounded it
was painful man because you just no
matter how great the band sounded you
just even the better the band sounded
the more i miss ronnie not being there
you know because it's
yeah yeah that's one of the this is one
of the best conversations i've had on
the podcast in my life yeah man you just
opened up my mind because you know what
made me call you the other day about two
weeks ago
three weeks ago i'm driving and i hear
uh diary of a man what the [ __ ] i heard
it on the way over isn't it it was on
today yeah yeah yeah that's crazy yeah
as i was pulling in
exactly
i couldn't believe it either and i was
in my house and i was thinking about
how different it would have like listen
in my world one day i went i had
sabotage war pigs and the first black
sabbath doll that's all i had yeah and
my friends called me and they go we got
an extra ticket to see sabbath and uh
some band i don't [ __ ] know at the
garden you come it was a cold night i
was a freshman in high school and i went
over there and i was blown away but my
friends were like they sucked and also
nazi and black sabbath break up
and it was february 19th it was bon
scott's the day bon scott died in 1980
and i'll never forget that i picked up
cream magazine
in those days that was your that's it
that's your bible that was it that was
it circus and cream
and cream had just stated that black
sabbath had just replaced
ozzy osbourne with walker first
before was ronnie james james dio and if
you go online they replaced
black ozzy osbourne with the singer from
savvy brown really as a matter of fact
go on youtube
and look for uh
the black sabbath even did tracks with
them it's [ __ ] painful to listen to
really i never even heard that yes
and you knew i only quit sabbath and
went to general tulle for two weeks yeah
and then came back he was like [ __ ] a
guy with a flute [ __ ]
i'm from [ __ ] birmingham i'm missing
a finger and you want to insult me with
the flute
which you know what say what you want to
say i had some good songs you hear
locomotive breath you want to run over a
homeless dude what man yeah you do you
hear sometimes you hear love when you
hear da da da da da da
that dude is no [ __ ] joke he's got
like two or three jazz that martin beret
goes off so you got to look for it it's
like black sabbath
the name of the band was savvy brown so
his name was like matt something
heaven and hell put heaven
having inhaled early recordings you guys
are gonna die that's crazy so this was
the question about why he's looking for
this i'm sitting there going
what if all this [ __ ] went down
when look at that
black sabbath heaven and hell live in
1980 no no
this is black sabbath
put with savoy brown
black sabbath was
i saw it on there and i couldn't believe
it they have early recordings
of they did a [ __ ] savoy brown was i
guess a band yeah yes
brown yeah yeah
there it is dave walker interview black
sabbath see all the way number four wow
he played with saturday wow
is that photoshop these days you know
we've seen the dave walker band how's
that going it's showing that all right
so fine black sabbath with dave walker
yeah yeah nobody even knew about that i
never knew that and i watched i watched
that sabbath two-part documentary you
know they had them for two songs wow it
was so [ __ ] painful isn't it
they said forget about it dave brown
dave walker i'm sorry yeah have you ever
seen a photo of a judas priest with the
original singer yeah
that's crazy it's not wrong how often do
you think it is
all right put on there it is right there
there it is what'd i tell you blacks
have a junior's eyes
listen it's
77.
i told you they were gonna do it with
him
this is the end of that i'll say this
oh [ __ ]
sounds like some 80s rock right
you got the looks that kill
well that's where they got it from
because this is 77 i know right
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
is it tony naomi playing a walk
i like it
a lot of people don't know this [ __ ]
it's heavy 70s right
it's kind of cactus
so we got nothing we got nothing and all
of a sudden
i see this ep at [ __ ] uh
in the village with the big whatever it
was
and it was the blizzard of oz but he had
tried to form he had tried to form the
blizzard years earlier
like in 75 well somebody gave him a
shirt right somebody gave him a shirt or
something
something happened early on
that he had thought about that my
question was
like i seen you guys at the palladium
and there was two shows that night yeah
think of this if if this would all went
down with the internet
and people would have known people
didn't know like i said there was cream
and [ __ ] circus that's it you know
and in those days you had to mail in for
tickets yeah i think i paid for your
tickets at the palladium but the shows
at the garden before that like yes and
all the who
all those shows that came to the garden
you had to mail in a money order for
four tickets and then they would send
you four tickets back in the mail you
knew that right it's so sketchy man no
that was how they worked but i'm saying
like what if your tickets got lost man
no it worked perfectly because you got
four of your buddies yeah you bought
four you bought four i bought four and i
bought four in those days let's say the
yes came came they came for five nights
so if you got four tickets for monday
you got four tickets for wednesday you
got four for thursday we got to see yes
four nights yeah so we went to see him
monday night and then we go back friday
and go wow they were a complete
different [ __ ] bag you go every night
you wouldn't like try to sell the
tickets no [ __ ] no i go everywhere no
for eight dollars ten dollars
i thought they were expensive oh there
was no idiot standing online
850
fifteen fifty fifteen fifty was like
[ __ ] orchestra seats yeah like 1950
was at the garden were like oh red seats
like that i got straight to the four
yeah straight to the floor i always went
straight that should be a good shirt
right van halen straight to the street
on a [ __ ] floor but it's just amazing
how different it would have been for
that band
that was so revolutionary at that time
right there boom they just came in the
blizzard of our struck perfect that's
why they blew up like they did in that
time
but it was if they would have had the
internet it would have been a [ __ ]
world
arena tour because everybody was waiting
for this yeah people were waiting for
[ __ ] ozzie to pull the trigger i
guess those last three
people just didn't really like i liked
them i loved it i love it never say die
in technical ecstasy people people not
technical ecstasy if you put technical
accessing on twitter yeah people will
hit your back rule number one of black
sabbath what's the thing from fight club
oh don't talk about technology
you don't know how many times i played
uh don't you won't change me yeah and
people have come back and said rule
number one of black sabbath
don't talk about technical access here
and i've giggled in the morning on jesus
[ __ ] christ
you know what's funny is um
i saw rudy i was um
seasoned i was a
sophomore in high school
their first super big gig dan the green
they play oakland so it's like heart
headlining
at heart and this 65 000 people at the
oakland a's stadium and i was only going
to see
uh
you know ozzy yeah we went on on like 10
30 in the morning yeah yeah yeah but i
gotta tell you
if you know you're talking about the
internet and all that not blowing up i
think that really helped us
to keep our [ __ ] together
just
think about the gig don't think about
what everybody else thinks about the
band
you know which is what would happen with
the internet you start getting messages
good or bad or whatever and then that
gets in the way you spend too much time
you know uh
you know
online you know social media no just
think about the gig you know those three
hours you're gonna spend on the internet
you're gonna be
you're gonna have your guitar on
yeah that's you know that makes sense
and also your head doesn't get filled
with [ __ ] like oh my god people are they
heard me play the and and they saw this
mistake that i made on in milwaukee on
the third
you know we used to go
to the mall
just about every day randy and i we used
to go to like you know bookstores to see
magazines if they
you know to see if if an interview that
ozzie gave three months ago was finally
printed
because that's how long it took you know
when when ozzy
actually one of his first circus
magazine interviews that was like three
months before you know when we were on
the road you know three months into the
tour that's when the actual
you know magazine came out it was
printed nowadays it's like
yeah you know it's overnight you know
somebody does an uh interview something
just push it over before the stage is
packed up it's already on yeah online
exactly
all of that and and you're so caught up
in what what he said this he said that
or people were thinking about what we're
doing no you just back in the day in
1981
we didn't know we just kept moving you
know we did a show today and well
tomorrow we got another show we're gonna
get up there and kick ass again that's
all that's all we were concerned with
well that gave me time to grow too and
and uh and organically to become this uh
killer [ __ ] band because if you're
reading stuff you might start second
guessing things yeah you might start
believing your own hype yeah you know uh
hendricks has one of my favorite quotes
uh it's uh i
don't like uh uh compliments because
they you know they get in the way of of
my playing i [ __ ] hate them you know
hendrix [ __ ] hate no i love hendrix
compliments i hate compliments oh yeah
yeah yeah after a [ __ ] show i [ __ ]
they drive me crazy
you know all that [ __ ] drives me [ __ ]
crazy because only you know how good you
were you know this is your expectation
yeah yes yeah we know yeah
when we walk up yeah and they go that
was the greatest near like now
that was pretty uh i call lee all the
time and leo saying how'd you do i hate
[ __ ] really i can't figure that out yeah
and i know if lee was there legal you
didn't eat [ __ ] but in my mind yeah i
ate [ __ ] i stumbled through this i
stumbled through that
it's uh
does it affect you when you make a
mistake
like but anyway it could be one mistake
that is so
small that if you hear back the the
playback of that show you you cannot
even hear it but it sticks in your mind
for the rest of the rest of the evening
and every other notice is correct just
that one note that you maybe like so it
might be like a little flub
that you you know it's it's within what
you play like 10 000 notes in a show and
it's that that one yeah they go oh [ __ ]
you know it's like that with jokes when
you when you do the joke just a hair
wrong you did the punch line first by
accident or something you're like i'm
[ __ ] here i just ruined the joke and
i'll tell them
tell them
listen i just [ __ ] up that joke
disregarded yeah and they'll get a laugh
and we laugh and we all know we all make
mistakes that makes you human
that makes you them you know what i'm
saying now you're even doing better
because all right i made a mistake [ __ ]
it you guys it's you know comedians what
you do
do you sometimes stretch it out because
we do that as musicians you know we
don't play exactly the same thing every
night sometimes you go like oh let me
try this other you know pentatonic riff
or whatever you know maybe in a
different position or something you guys
do variations like that absolutely oh
every night it's different
absolutely i can't go on stage and do
the exact [ __ ] night after night
after night no way i gotta switch it up
and if one night i get rid of a [ __ ] so
[ __ ] be it if some night somebody
gets hit with a glass and i riff on it
it's funny for 20 minutes
[ __ ] it they got their money's worth a
different way we still laughed about
something totally you know i like to be
in the moment i love for something to
happen they don't have to tell jokes
yeah i love it yeah yeah like bill hicks
would say the act is last
yeah i mean what would be your
equivalent of jamming because you know
in a band you know your crowd work
how would the crowd
this guy's killer at it i used to be
really really good at it yeah but it
didn't get you nowhere that doesn't
cause too much commotion and comics that
follow you now you leave them open to
talk to him yeah
so you have to be really careful with it
if you develop in new york for some
reason you do it a lot more
to kill material and i was doing it for
a long time and then i had to stop
sometimes if i'm rocking and rolling and
i got him already then you [ __ ] around a
little bit you know what i'm saying just
go not every show though you do it like
maybe once every 10 shows i see yeah no
it's terrible because i don't want to it
was such a bad habit yeah you know the
worst thing you could do is anything a
musician
is pick up a bad habit when i was a
basketball player i used to take the
rebound i used to be a great rebounder
but i get the rebound and put it on the
floor why the [ __ ] are you bouncing the
[ __ ] ball yeah it took years to break
that habit
and i saw it how as a comic you get into
a [ __ ] habit and boom you know for a
long time i had this habit of wanting
silence
who what comic wants silence yeah
because i was testing them i would try
to
we just go through so many phases yeah
and you try so many [ __ ] different
things and you have to to stay who you
are you have to try different [ __ ]
things yeah yeah i just yeah i'm more
conscious of them now because people are
paying for the tickets yeah do you
understand me yeah i'm more conscious
now yeah you know when i go to comedy it
used to be that monday tuesday wednesday
he went to the economy store i wouldn't
even think about it down the road
because i wanted that organic joke to
come out there's nothing like uh there's
nothing like
40 people which is 80 set of eyes
looking at you
pressure you know it's like
i stated something when i watched a
ronda rousey fight that you could tell
that she didn't get punched in the face
during practice
nobody hit her
it's equivalent to a comic doing
material in front of a mirror nothing
bad is going to happen to you you're
going to do great every time it's like
it's like when you beat up a punching
bag who loses yeah who loses to a
punching bag yeah you got to get out
there yeah you know you got to get out
there yeah i can't imagine how
a band does it like everybody in note
every night tight and sure the tour
starts a little [ __ ] up
but after he always does he always does
but after a year jesus [ __ ] christ
jesus [ __ ] christ you know yeah
and never
i'm sorry how do you because when it's
joey or or dean you can make a decision
to change your joke you don't tell
anybody
you guys do do you have a signal or how
do you let them know during a show when
there's 50 000 people cheering how do
you say oh i'm gonna go a little bit
long here or do you plan it
uh that's a really good question i gotta
tell you if you're in a band you're
playing for in front of 50 000 people
every show is gonna be
the same every night
and i'll tell you why because of
production and once the production got
huge and automated technology came in
and all the lighting directors you know
there's actually guys the lds who
actually come in and they not only
program but they create a stage
show
very rarely does the guy who actually
creates the production
goes on tour with the band i know a few
but mostly there's guys who make a
living out of you know they get a phone
call from band a and he goes there and
designs that all the lighting the
lighting rig everything he'll program it
and it's
the the guy who goes on the road his job
is to push buttons and make you know he
he might stop the the the lighting
sequence between songs but usually it's
all rigged which means that you as a
musician you have to know where to stand
each spot on stage every song every
section of the song because otherwise
you're going to be dark yeah bombs and
fire too oh yeah all the time oh yes
fire absolutely smoke absolutely so
there's no room for for uh jamming you
know uh
because everything is it the bigger the
band the bigger the production
the more constraints you have as a
musician to do everything
exactly the same night and a lot of
bands have backup tracks backing tracks
so that's that's even more restrictions
there because you gotta be start the
song and end the song exactly this
on the same bar every night they play to
a metronome and these background vocals
trigger right on the spot it's called
radar it runs perfectly with the song so
if you're off a little the backgrounds
will come on later so exactly you know
you're like oh [ __ ] yeah
so you know things started changing back
around the middle of the 80s when when
bands are getting automated productions
before that you know like when i was
working with with uh you know with ozzy
even uh blizzard of us it was just a
bunch of guys get up there and you start
the song sometimes ozzie will walk off
the stage
and disappear yeah and a couple of dudes
with those spotlights remember they'd
climb up before the show that's how you
knew the show was starting remember the
guys would go up those those scary ass
rope ladders and be up there with their
[ __ ] spots and that was the lighting
yeah you know it's so super cool
i saw you in
april of 81 and then
randy died in may of eighty-two march
march
82 yeah and then the tour came back
through my hometown with brad
willis
which show was that uh diary of a madman
they played the meadowlands meadowlands
the outbreak and it was [ __ ] a
different stage yeah because i remember
yeah there's not much you could [ __ ]
do was a picture ozzy some dragons and
whatever but once you got to the
meadowlands that october
the [ __ ]
opened up and the castle and now that
you can't stretch you know you watch uh
vh1 every every other friday they got
the song remains the same oh yeah i love
it and they headed it down and they cut
it and they put tracks in and the whole
thing but you could see they were just
up there but there was no production
there was two explosions yeah during uh
yeah no no
oh yeah yeah i know and that was the
[ __ ] wawa thing with the hand
beside that they would just look at each
other and just [ __ ] go right bottom
would just control the show those guys
were jammed yeah they just jammed you
know jam that's not gonna happen today
where you know you're gonna come up
we're talking about curfews yeah oh yeah
well union uni
triple time triple times the green coats
in the garden you know i remember going
to the garden and seeing the new
barbarians and they went on to [ __ ]
12 [ __ ] the union you know but that cost
you don't realize it but then you go
years later to see don henley at
fiddler's green and you got to be off by
9 45. those white people will [ __ ]
call the cops on your dog yeah they pull
the plug right in the middle of the
[ __ ] song red rocks is very nice they
got a [ __ ] curfew too up there yeah
it's so weird how you figure somebody
goes up and goes listen we're pulling a
dave chappelle yeah we're doing every
[ __ ] song we ever wrote okay
backwards yeah we're here till two in
the
they morning every rec song they ever
wrote one concert
every song it was like eight records or
something they did it
every house of blues that i played at
there's there's a there's a clock on the
side of the stage right yeah yeah yeah
everywhere that's everywhere yeah and if
you go over one minute yeah you start
ducking like you know a thousand dollars
triple time yeah
it's amazing that's the house of blues
yeah yeah you know there's something
really weird going on lately
with music
that i've been reading not reading about
just heard things about what's going on
with the eagles
something's [ __ ] up
they're receiving an award but i guess
they told the long-haired guy he can't
show up yeah and
they i mean the guy wrote hotel
california something happened to glenn
fry though he's getting the surgery and
he said from years of partying or
whatever he had to go in and get a
surgery and they're going to get the
award uh next time they pushed it a year
so he went into surgery google google
that glenn frye surgery recently
something happened to him but yeah the
other guy don feldner's out
like he's [ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah like he's like i don't know what i
did you know he's but if he wants that
documentary you see him [ __ ] up
throughout the thing you know he wants
to sing i'm a singer like when they get
to the long run record and you know
everybody wants the the thing was they
promised him they were going to sing
yeah they always promised them a song
and i guess they pulled them out of the
studio for lunch and they had what's his
name don henley
and then they said why would we have you
sing when we have don henley yeah he
said that uh he but they also said that
would come back to haunt them yeah
and then when they got back you know
when they got back or something
something they went out as uh
they weren't really abandoned anymore
they were something like employees oh
yeah yeah
four of them were the band and don
felder became the employee that was when
hell freezes over to her nine seconds i
told him he goes this is the deal you do
i mean they don't like him at all you
could see and i figured he's like the
guy that's still doing drugs like they
showed up to rehearse like with the
bottle and they're like uh
we got shorthand now oh my god
we got our money suits on uh you brought
budweiser i came in a lamborghini yeah
you know he showed up in a [ __ ] z28
and a 12-pack like we're back
and the eagles are like uh we're getting
250 a ticket yeah you find it
yeah it's exactly what you said just due
to all of his partying he needed to push
it back a year yeah a whole year so
something's wrong with him
he said he was going in to get a surgery
you know well they only award those
things once yeah once again the kennedy
honors kennedy
yeah so that's what it was they think
that they feel that everybody should
show randy meisner
everybody should show but the ego's like
nah i feel that too of us i feel that uh
anybody that was there to keep you going
through the eras should be up there even
with the rock and roll hall of fame you
know you can uh i mean when it came down
to kiss guys you know
uh you got
peter
and ace
definitely should be there and they
should play together you know don't you
think so
i don't know
i think this is really an anomaly yeah
because it's kind of like a
ah it's kind of like like a team and a
teammate by that i mean it's uniforms
right there's a kiss uniform which is
the their costume their costumes and the
makeup and it's even there's a copyright
to
those things right
and
well like a kiss without the makeup
business-wise yeah wasn't as big as kiss
with the makeup when it got back
together again with the makeup and
i mean we're talking different between
as a matter of fact kiss supported white
snake in 1990
with other makeup
they come back with it with the makeup
and they're headlining dodger stadium
yeah you know so it's it's that's really
an anomaly in the business i'm just
talking about rock and roll hall of fame
or whatever or awards where guys were on
records and wrote songs and stuff oh
absolutely yeah from that point yeah as
far as musical contribution yep yeah
absolutely well i would have to imagine
that
since the love is so big for those
people you were talking about that the
hate would probably be just as big if
you hated somebody
you're probably not gonna want to be but
you know what when you as a band get
into a room and decide listen guys we're
going to be completely different from
everybody else rewrite some of the rules
of rock and roll and the music industry
and we're going to put these outfits on
that's really going to separate you from
everybody and that to me that becomes a
a corporation that's a business decision
to do that they they
they say listen we can't really compete
with led zeppelin or whoever because
we're not we might not be as as good as
they are
but what we can do is create this and
they created this mega
you know corporation kiss yeah it's a
show it's a show it's the show it's what
it is you know and it's to me yeah
they're they're really good players
i think gina is a really good bass
player yeah i think he's really
underrated
but business-wise that was genius
that's where the genius of kiss really
lies in creating kiss
the whole kiss is it's a kiss world kiss
empire incredible right even the manager
pillow coin genius i mean it's just
[ __ ] the whole thing is
totally genius
never done again i mean tried to but
never like you know i mean you couldn't
do it now because of dmz and [ __ ] you
never saw those guys faces for like 10
years
it was just bandanas i tell you when i
when i uh moved to l.a
in the mid 70s i got a job at a place
called mcnaturals right across from
tower records on sunset and on my first
day i'm learning the uh the register
you know and i'm like and i look up and
there's paul stanley you knew it was him
he looked like paul stanley without the
makeup wow and i'm like
you know like oh my god and so he orders
he's ordered the same thing here every
at every time that he came in was a uh
wonder of the orient which was a
brussels sprout
and salad with a
scoop of tuna
and a
a small carrot juice
he had that every single time
your memory is incredible i love him
like when i had john the podcast he can
drop dates and and uh you know how many
times have paul stanley come into your i
know i know
you got a great memory man because
sometimes i start getting foggy it was
like what year is that you know what i
mean it's like i saw
sabbath and ozzy or whatever but then i
only know like maybe one or two years
because of when blizzard and diary came
out after that you're like i don't know
it was in the 80s or 90 you know what i
mean you know i was thinking about the
other when i was in new york last week
i was driving and heaven and hell came
on
and i thought about
how much i wanted to hate that [ __ ]
album
like as a true aussie fan like when when
they split like i was going with ozzy
like [ __ ] black sabbath all right [ __ ]
black sabbath i don't need this [ __ ] in
my life
and heaven and hell came out the album
and i remember like
i ain't buying that [ __ ]
and then like guy tabasco the tabasco
family next door they all had long hair
they went to van halen they bought it
and they were like you got to listen to
them dog i'm not listening to this [ __ ]
there was no more of an album than i
wanted to fail in that arm and today i
love the [ __ ] house i love the album
and d.o bothered me first time i saw dio
was in philadelphia at the spectrum with
shaken street
and
what's his name the singer from van
halen oh
sammy hagar sammy hagar and shaken
street
and ronnie montrose wow and
and i drove from jersey to philly
was it gamma the band gamma monsters no
no it was ronnie then i saw him again
open up for ac dc at the national
coliseum yeah ronnie montrose but he was
so weird i was mantras shaken street and
they were spitting at sammy hagar
because philadelphia they got no class
they're savages those people at the
spectrum they would and they couldn't
spit long range so they would spit on
their fingers and flicker
and you would see sammy hagar singing
and the spit flying over
and then theo came out and they opened
up with war pigs and i was insulted
yeah like i'm like what is he doing and
i'm like what the [ __ ] is going on here
and we had six row tickets and my friend
did purple he thought it was acid but he
fell asleep at the show so for years we
kept saying dog remember the time he did
those purple loots they weren't [ __ ]
lewds they were acid [ __ ] i was tired
but he came out he's like generals
gathered
in their masses
just i'm like no we gotta go
we gotta go dawg we gotta go this guy's
out there [ __ ] butchering
i was furious he was a short little guy
deal dressed in black and
then they did warping he did something
different yeah like it was different and
i was into let's give this guy a shot
and then he stole my heart man in a
weird way
d.o had me competing you know it was
like it was the album you wanted to
[ __ ] hate with everything i got you
know i wanted to hate it i ended up
seeing the tour like two times yeah well
we got lucky they broke up because we
got four masterpiece records we got the
blizzard diary
um uh mob rules and heaven and hell so
she my bruise i had already tapped no
that [ __ ] record actually also uh the
dehumanizing human rights
amazing we get
dehumanizer yeah which by the way is it
really good oh yeah and i'll tell you
what i was trying to do what year was
that oh i don't know late 80s yeah late
80s okay because i remember still
uh only diver whatever the [ __ ] oh well
he he that's a song that's a soul that
was 83. yeah you got holy dog whatever
was in 83
last in line all that [ __ ] we should we
should let you listen to it for the
first time what's a good song from
dehumanizing oh no uh play dehumanizer
the actual song yeah yeah it's
unbelievable really yeah check it out
yeah 89 i was doing something different
yeah also people up and [ __ ] i tell i
talk about this record over and over and
over and over
born again which everyone hated and i
saw the tour was ian gillan in in
sabbath
hands down one of my favorite records
ever made really and i saw the tour it
was empty at the cow palace and it was
really weird and and a weird vibe but i
loved it man when we were on the bill it
was sold out every single night
unbelievable i mean we mean quiet right
yeah yeah right the opening band for for
them on the east coast how great was
that record 83 yeah
here you go here's some dehumanizer
show them what the cover looks like
this is savage oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's great
listen
yeah this is too much
great smoking some bunkers listen how
great is that yeah we used to do that
song without with ronnie on on tour
called i yeah i
it's a crowd i wouldn't even dare even
try you know yeah to sing you know
it would be so funny we will be you know
with uh touring with dio and we used to
do a lot of uh scandinavian uh
you know countries finland and so on you
know and finland it they're very in
norway or very well known for it for
like black metal you know the the bands
that go on and burn churches down and
like you know if they have a chick
singer she sings like oh girl
you know yeah cookie monster chick
singer you know and and so
they would always you know come and pay
respects you know to running you know
after their show they will come in and
and into our dressing room and say we're
running
you're you're the reason why i sing
oh that's aware
like always shake your hand be polite
and then they will leave and go do i
sound like that
i tell you what
mob rules has dio's best song ever
sign of the southern cross oh my god
it's his best song ever yeah and if you
don't know it i remember the album
the actual song signed of the southern
cross is the most epic dio song ever
check it out it's falling off the edge
of the world that's another oh yeah yeah
over the sea oh my god these ones where
they're really kind of ballady and he
can get into it when when uh when ronnie
joined uh heaven and hell the band
heaven hell which is you know black
sabbath by another name you know uh we
stopped playing black salad songs so we
actually went deeper into the deal
catalog and rainbow catalog where that's
that's another incredible ronnie james
theo era terror woman oh my terrible
open up with that yeah he only did two
albums with raymond i think three three
two three three three star gazer
uh that would be the first one that's
the first one where the original well
actually with elf
elf the elf band without the original
guitar player yeah
and then uh rainbow rising and yeah yeah
and uh long live rock and roll that's it
long roads rocket this is the huge
i remember one day i was going down the
road in my car with satellite radio and
i go what dio song is this i don't i've
had all the deal and i was like holy
[ __ ] rainbow and it's only like 4.99 on
itunes right now that record it's uh
it's got tarot woman you know and it's
like six songs and it's an incredible
rainbow record yeah um and the genius of
richie blackmore what an underrated
guitar player because everybody talks
about jeff beck and eric clapton and
jimmy page
check out richie blackmore were you
friends with with her richie no i knew i
never met him what did you hear about
him personally from ronnie they had the
greatest sense of humor ever wow yeah he
said he was the funniest guy ever to be
around
yeah
why didn't he ever keep a singer
yeah that's crazy that's right i never
i never again tony bennett why the [ __ ]
didn't he ever keep a singer
i i always heard little rumblings of him
or what is he alive still oh yeah oh
yeah he's coming out this summer he got
a new singer and they're doing rainbow
yeah
here you go
oh tony bennett i want to be
i was on his side of the southern cross
where no i just uh somebody breaks
you know i let go of music like once i i
went into the world it was over for me i
had to dive in i had no more time to sit
there the [ __ ] i was doing i had a
diamond dog there was no time i hear you
right here
on the streets so i had lost that whole
uh
that whole music thing in my life and i
was lost you know
i didn't get back into music until guns
and roses appetite for destruction that
woke me up out of my musical coma
and i still didn't go see him enough it
was just something that i listened to i
bought that a couple hours but i was
lost for a long time good record to
bring you back yeah
man you know i talked to uh
what's amazing about rudy is what people
don't know is
and i had them on the podcast is
they
were the first band quiet riot they
opened the door for motley crew
and everything after it well they say
that one of the best documentaries right
now that's why yeah that's great even
one of my friends said it is phenomenal
it is just it really breaks down i guess
they had the number one single of all
time or the heaviest metal albums first
band man the the first metal
what was you because metal today is very
different from what was considered metal
30 years ago you know it has evolved so
we were considered metal
uh and we were the first debut record to
reach number one see i always thought
that led zeppelin and everybody else had
done that thriller they knocked thriller
yeah we had to knock the thriller off
the number one spot to get to number one
yeah
we were selling a million a week yeah he
said they remember those masks
they were selling a a million of those
masks on tour on the kevin de bruyne
yeah yeah yeah
unbelievable a million i know this is
well three okay okay check this out back
in the day
the average was about 750 ahead
merchandise you know so you have 10 000
people
in the arena the average average out to
75 grand a night in merchandising
without credit cards we're talking cash
and would you would the band get that
well it was our money and then you know
we would pay whatever
uh to the merchandising company you know
they will take a
percentage and this is before the time
when when like uh you know now you have
like life nation they own a lot of the
uh venues and they take about 30 to 40
percent of your merchandising money
back then they didn't know yeah they
didn't you just set up your shirts and
walked with your cash they take 40 of
your shirts oh yeah now yeah merchandise
oh you guys should just like give them a
card to your website then that's too
much to give up
well here's the thing now also
record deals are done on 360 deals
because there's no record sales so when
you sign a record deal now you give the
label part of your merch your touring
and your record sales yeah or if you you
know like for example life nation all
these other companies that have a deal
where they actually buy your record
you know you make them you make a record
and then they buy your record they give
you a set amount of money for your tour
and the merchandise so they own
everything you just have to show up and
and do your gig an all-in deal yeah a
lot of times you'll tell the guy hey put
me on the list like a huge band like say
madonna and they go yeah i got to pay
for your ticket exactly because they've
been paid one lump sum for the tour yep
well the stones were one of the first
ones to do that exactly that's how i
know about it so much yeah you have
auctions and and whoever the promoter
won the auction he bought every he owned
every every seat everything if you were
keith richards and you wanted your your
uncle to come to the show you had to buy
that ticket because you were paid a lump
sum up front
it's pretty wild like people would be
like what do you mean you don't got no
guest list yeah you you really want that
guy to come if he's in your seat you
know what i mean yeah
it's crazy how the music industry has
just changed
completely and it still [ __ ] you guys
it's still out to [ __ ] you guys
it always has that it's never been music
it's never been a [ __ ] paradise right
yeah you hear the stories and you go
what
oh what are you talking about these guys
sold more records than anybody what was
the label quiet right the first one
the uh pasha yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know and i still in order for me to get
my money i have to call my lawyer which
costs me money
to get my money
so yeah they gave me my money eventually
at some point but i got to pay my lawyer
for that you know a lot of money for
like years he didn't get paid he had to
battle to get it oh god yeah for about
seven years we were uh you know we had
to go to court okay so it's 1983 yeah
quiet riot gets this album ready
you break it down for me
break it down from a to [ __ ] z
just break down how it happens you guys
have your eight songs
who was the album who was the label
uh it was pasha records
who else did they have pasha at the time
they had billy something billy billy
square no billy ocean no something
children of the sun billy
billy yeah children of the sun
yeah yeah i know that tune yeah all
right so they had position
distributed uh interesting because pasha
as a production company had distribution
through different labels one of them was
capital okay ours happened to be with
with uh cbs update at the time yeah yeah
you get the album
you sit down we're going to do the album
how much do you get paid for the album
there's five guys in the band four
four randy rhodes no no no randy was
oh yeah i mean but
no it was all done on demo
time demo is a pasha on the studio
and let's say you
cancelled a a session
uh
the engineer will call you know one of
the guys and say hey listen we got time
open for you guys to come in because we
didn't have a deal yet it was all done
on specs spec time it's great time yeah
so
which you know
after you get signed that's when you pay
for for the studio time it's in good
faith they're thinking you're gonna get
a deal you get a little heat and they go
look this ban has heat yeah we wanted to
use your studio in the middle of the
night like 2 a.m we'll pay if they get a
deal yeah okay exactly speculation yeah
okay spec deal okay so now you and the
boys got a call and you went in how long
to lay the album down well you know what
while
while the guys were laying down basic
tracks i was still in aussie so my the
first time that i walked in the studio
to to record on the album was to do one
song called thunderbird
that i used to play with kevin and his
band do bro and then
uh when randy passed away
uh he asked me to come in to do that as
a
tribute to randy on the record and so i
that was the first song i recorded then
we had extra time and the guy said
listen do you remember slick black
cadillac let's get crazy you know songs
that i
select black i used to play with randy
in quiet riot and then we did that in
dubrow and then uh let's get crazy on
the other songs which i already knew
from the bro so by the time i left i i
laid down like four or five songs from
the album but i was still ozzy's bass
player you know
and
and again you know getting back to the
thing about playing from pain
it was very painful for me after randy
died you know to keep playing with ozzy
you know so
i here i am with the guys from choir
ryan or kevin and frankie and
and carlos and
and i said god you know this feels good
i i feel like yeah this is like a joy i
just joined my playing again you know
which is what i what i wanted in my life
you know
so i i li here i am i leave one of the
biggest bands in the world ozzy for like
the total unknown quiet riot you know
that's how much pain i had which by the
way what he's not saying is no one
wanted quiet ryan well yeah for years so
it's a gamble well not only quiet riot
but the whole music scene the heavy
metal yeah 1982 la it was all you know
yeah new way from punk that was it if
you were not in in a new way for punk
band record companies don't want to know
anything about you you know uh when when
you said that choir riot opened the door
what happened was choir riot
created a
a uh uh uh
created some some sort of within the
industry
a
opened the eyes of the executives that
there is a market for rock bands and so
you know just like it happened with
nirvana in seattle
you know they record a record companies
locally in los angeles are saying hey
these guys came from the strip who else
is on the strip well you have motley
crew who's been around you got rat and
you got
uh dawkin and then great white and so on
so okay well these guys are ready to go
let's sign them up too and you know
promote them and make mtv videos and so
on so basically that's what happened
it's not like
like we
you know we invented anything
you know we were there
but so were the other guys ready to go
you know so that opened the door as far
as like creating an awareness that
that type of music that we were all
doing there was a market for
you know and something that i i got a
glimpse of it because it was already
happening in england and europe
you know with bands like saxon you know
ozzy opened up for saxon in 1981 that
was part of our diary of embed mentor
you know in in october of 1981 october
november
uh
we also we had motorhead we have def
leppard so i was aware of like
uh maiden made they made me was another
band you know all those guys that later
became mtv staple that's another thing
mtv mtv was responsible for creating all
of that
lightning in a bottle right right at the
right time all right so now you put this
outfit down yeah they do the cover with
the [ __ ] mask just come on feel the
noise yep correct well that was the
second second single second video first
one was mental health yeah bang yours
when you see a dollar when is your first
dollar come in
at this time yeah i as a matter of fact
the guys were getting gas money
during the making of the record there
was no advances no nothing it was a
production deal it was like you go you
you record the record and we're gonna
try to put this out with a major label
as a distributor you know marketing
promotion all that
so there was no advances nothing you
know which meant that we recoup
immediately you know i think it the cost
of the album was like 32 grand
yeah to tape
that was it yeah including electricity
and tape and everything yeah yeah 32
which means that
we recoup
really fast but also you have to take
into consideration when you sign a
production deal
it's it's a difference between a cake
and a muffin
the cake being the big the big pot where
everything comes out of you know and
then a production deal is a percentage
of the production deal another
percentage of the deal
because you have the the major label
being the big pot the big piece you know
the
the big slice so our slice was smaller
because it was predicated from
the production deal
you know sidemen
it's like a middleman deal a middleman
deal
yeah part of the contract is they give
you money and then album sale money
correct for the band
or just the writers of the songs oh no
no no
yeah
record sales yeah for life you get this
well we still do okay yeah because i met
people in boulder who were radio cops
yeah that there's two guys in both
that's what they did for a living they
made sure you guys got your money like
ass cap guys well ask a bmi yeah yeah
and now it's done it's different
everything old songs are coded and yeah
yeah
yeah
it's it's it's a different world i mean
now we i make money from uh
from uh airplay
and we didn't before musicians never
used to make money from airplay now uh
anything being
what what they call non-terrestrial
broadcast
uh we'll make money
from airplay
yeah it could be it could be computer xm
siriusxm whatever satellite yeah i met
somebody in hollywood 15 years ago
nice kid
and once i asked him
don't you work
and he goes yeah i'm on tour with
the band that used to jump up and down
not the [ __ ] guy samara is kind of
i'm so hard
so in the end it really doesn't matter
not those guys oh but before the park
before them there was a guy in the
guitar
and he was big and they jumped around
and he was they were going to make a
comeback and they were huge i don't know
sugar ray
like a sugar rage
he was a good-looking guy he was kind of
bald he was in a band and he was dating
strippers he was oh oh the guy's uh now
he crazy town no and now they do
something else in park no it's not
lincoln park it doesn't really matter
yeah i know that was like a park it was
around that area anyway they make a long
story short they were on tour
they were big and he's he's producing
now they kept threatening to come back
with a new guitarist for a long time
limp biscuit limp biscuit oh there you
go okay what's the guy's name
yeah i mean
monkey no that's corn west portland
that was opening on the road they had a
song on the radio he told him he goes
let me
because my song is on the radio this kid
was broke wow and i go how do you make
money he goes we're going on the road
to pay the advance to do the song
what are you talking about i didn't know
how i mean this kid was living off of me
and i had no money like if i wouldn't
got a burrito i'd buy my burrito or
something like that like a breakfast
[ __ ] bagel yeah and i'm like how the
[ __ ] are you on tour and he was telling
me breaking it down and he lived around
the corner with his girlfriend his
girlfriend i guess maintained and but
this kid was [ __ ] opening up for limp
biscuit yeah on the road cool like he
was home for two weeks
broke wow and he was telling me how the
this is 2000 this is when they were you
know napster and all this [ __ ] 98
whatever all this [ __ ] how is that no
money and you're on tour
don't they give you nothing so you're
just on tour paying back the record
label
for the videos or something like that
no no that's separate i mean the way
that it used to be back in the day
the label did not touch anything of your
live performance
that was back then
yeah now it's a 360 deal though yeah
yeah now it's completely different but
back then you know there was a
separation between label and touring you
know they
they were not tied in yeah so your money
was yours from touring yeah from touring
uh but then again that's uh but they
would give you tour support
which meant yeah yeah
and it went into your into the promotion
or and you know of the album cost yeah
but you paid for everything bosses sound
man
and it was a recuperable of course you
know tour support
yeah like you look at this guy like ozzy
who did nine albums
and came out of there with nothing
well
like
well right there's two different sides
yeah yeah no i mean this is what
happened uh
uh aussie was signed uh through
management and as manager you know don
arden jet jet jet management and jet
records he was signed to the label again
another production deal
they were on epic epic through jet
records so if you look at an aussie
record this is a jet uh jet records uh
label right
and um so again it was one of those
situations and sharon was part part of
the management team her dad was there
but i gotta tell you they invested uh
jet records
invested money in aussie they uh they
they believed in him you know that's all
that first tour blizzard of oz that was
finance advanced by jed records who was
also the manager
ozzy's manager yeah yeah
so they really believed in him yeah you
know it was a huge risk a couple weeks
ago we had somebody on here and we were
talking about
the abuse that the beatles did to this
country like these kids are too [ __ ]
young but if you were around in 66 67
you know the beatles were claiming that
paul was dead
you know he's walking around barefoot
and sergeant peppers and all this shit's
going you know beetle fans had it the
hardest beetle fans like catholics they
took a [ __ ] beat then when they broke
up they kept threatening they were going
to come back you know anytime anybody
got popular i went to see this band's
easy top they're [ __ ] great some jerk
off from the room will go yeah yeah yeah
wait till the beatles come back they
ain't bad and you lose the argument you
know what i'm saying like but then john
lennon got shot and a little piece he
was like thank god he got shot
because now the beatles ain't getting
back together and i win my argument you
know saying led zeppelin is [ __ ]
better than beatles you know yeah but
it's so weird how all right all that
[ __ ] went down with the beatles and all
that time
that music is so important to bring the
country back like in the seventies like
i was watching that cnn show on the
seventh day they told me that and they
had 1973
there was two billion dollars in music
ticket sales
that's how many tours right 73 73 who
wasn't touring
not only that i mean tickets were like
10 bucks or five bucks that's a lot of a
lot of touring to come up with that much
money these are [ __ ] dollars that's
[ __ ] cool but if you look and you go
because you know me i'm a [ __ ]
nutcase i'm gonna i'm gonna holla i'm
gonna come i'm gonna hold tylenon
in some [ __ ] town jump down the road
as soon as i saw that i went online you
had to see it's like who wasn't on tour
yeah in 1973.
who was it yeah
stone zeppelin the purple the purple
alice cooper black sabbath yeah al john
david bowie
john was killing him 73 he was just
starting to [ __ ] get warmed up right
stewart
if you think about it each ticket
averaged out to ten dollars that's 200
million seats yep
that they sold yeah it's crazy easy did
you watch that special they're doing the
80s comes out in april i couldn't find
it man
how [ __ ] hard heart incredible they
showed them i mean
sita
the chubby one was [ __ ] skinny oh
yeah and that blonde came out and
started doing this bolero type thing
like
like the light was just on her
you know
so it's there was so much [ __ ] money
where'd this [ __ ] money go eagles and
you hear all these stories you hear you
know you hear ccr another guy that
didn't get [ __ ] a dime he didn't sign
something or something not a dime and
yeah that's the other thing that's how
you wrote that good music you know you
you sit here and you say to yourself you
know what i did coke for 20 years i
didn't get nothing good out of it oh
yeah something had to come good because
all those [ __ ] wrote all those
songs
and they were [ __ ] writing all those
movies the exorcist they didn't write
that on
mocha lattes from starbucks i tell you
that you know you just brought something
up you know yeah that just happened you
know lately
it's it's you know i grew up with 60s
music and every single
band that mattered to me had a political
statement
you know politics and rock and roll have
never been divided they've been united
it's not as a matter of fact i think
that the best music came out of the six
is just because of that
you know people have something to say
something to stand for nowadays i go
online and
i don't even make a commentary i just
post something that somebody also posted
i get i got flamed people telling me oh
listen no we want to hear your political
views because we just want to enjoy your
music
you know [ __ ] you first of all it's my
freedom of speech
you know my right
to express myself second of all this is
the problem with music today it's like
most band most artists don't have a
political point of view just because
they're afraid of like i'm gonna offend
somebody
you know the best music you go back to
the 60s ccr you know
uh what is it the fortunate sign
unfortunate son
what better political statement than
that yeah you know nowadays it's like oh
you're going to offend somebody if you
you know write a song like that look at
the doors you know apocalypse now
soundtrack it's all freaking doors music
you know that's what they were in the
jungle that's what they were listening
to they were listening to the doors man
you know
john lennon doing a sit-in
at a hotel room you know give peace a
chance you know all of this you know
different political views whatever but
people had something to say and it was
the musicians
most of the time
bob dylan another one who actually gave
you something to hold on to something to
to believe in you know to stand by and
say yes i agree with you thank you for
putting it together into a song that i
can actually you know
feel it
you know get in my heart in my soul you
know
it was very interesting on that on that
special they spoke about how marvin gaye
went to motown and said look that's
another one you should look it bro
i like what you're doing but i ain't
doing that [ __ ] with five black guys
dancing behind me you think i'm kidding
you that's what he told him what's the
[ __ ] special he goes i ain't no
cookie cutter i'm not doing that i want
to write a song about what's going on
yeah and he wrote what's going on yeah
and it was brilliant and then stevie
wonder was in his office he said i want
to do what he's doing yeah i ain't doing
it he put out four yeah albums in a row
that only match pink floyd's run that
that dark side metal animals wall
animals like stevie wonder because they
had something to say i mean the the end
it ended with uh songs in the key of
life which i was a little [ __ ] kid
and i remember my mom at the bar my head
almost [ __ ] and blew up
you're right they did have something to
that's what changed the music the stats
would make you sympathy for the devil
yeah you know listen to those lyrics if
that's if that's if those are not
political social political statements
you know you're not
you know you're not reading it right
absolutely yeah and their whole battle
like against the taxes and and going
into exile and riding exile on main
street like [ __ ] you you ain't taking
our money anymore you know back then 50
you know they blazed lived in a house
and lived in exile
keep all their money
rad
you know
you know you brought a
a good point up last time you were on
the show and i'm doing it this year i'm
going to like three or four shows this
year i've planned to go into three or
four shows let my mind shut down
black sabbaths being one of them i don't
care what the ticket cost yeah hollywood
bowl well everybody's complaining the
tickets prices are too high they're
doing the bowl of the forum they're
doing both okay i think i'll do
hollywood bowl i'm going to see david
gilmore i'm going to that okay at the
ball at the bowl yeah okay
uh there was somebody else i wanted to
see this year because that's it you're
right you're never gonna get a chance to
see this again i
for years i i just i didn't want to go
see somebody
sing with a lip machine or whatever the
[ __ ] it is but you know what i don't
give a [ __ ] i want to go you know
everybody said that for years he had a a
guy behind a curtain that sang from [ __ ]
like the wizard of oz or something like
that you know what i'm gonna [ __ ] go
it's inspiring well the only way to
write so the only way to be creative is
to uh get entertained
totally sometimes you have to go get
entertained you know uh one thing about
rudy is you see all those old kennison
things rudy was a fan of stand up yeah
rudy likes stanford that's how we met
that's how we met big time he saw me at
the nokia
and uh he came backstage and he said man
you were great where was this at who
were you i was opening for artie lange
yeah the opening party yeah i went there
with rich
you know and he came back and i was like
oh rudy sorry i was all over him like a
[ __ ] maniac kid
and uh
and he said you were great man and then
he came to some other shows and stuff
and and did the podcast and and we
became great friends you know but he is
a comedy guy and then and then i forgot
about the wild thing and all that and i
was like oh my god he was with sam at
the store and wild thing and all that i
got to tell you most musicians that i
know they think that they're [ __ ]
funny they think they're comedians
that's all we do and the bus you know we
we we take our music serious and then we
get off and we're just like [ __ ]
around all the time
and i think yeah 40 percent of comedians
are musicians that didn't have the balls
to go through with it
like i still have doubts about going and
picking up a guitar because i know i'm
scared
i know what's going to happen yeah but
how more scary can it be then just stand
there with the mic in your hand and you
tell the jokes
i'm scared of how it's going to take
over my life yeah i could see me at 56
doing a [ __ ] uh rudy sargo cover band
you follow me yeah yeah i could see
myself doing it i could see it i could
just go i could see myself playing
getting enthralled with it now telling
my wife [ __ ] you
i'm going to go on the road every week
and do comedy but meanwhile all i really
want to do is get in the hotel room and
play my [ __ ] guitar instead of
snorting coke in the old days it was
snorting coke sure i'll go on the road
christmas eve yeah alaska i'm there
so all i wanted to do was snort coke
that's the only way i could do it by
getting away from my girlfriend yeah so
i could see me doing the same thing i
loved the guitar that much you think you
would travel with it oh [ __ ] yeah listen
[ __ ] these punk-ass [ __ ] who travel
with skateboards listen i travel every
week and every [ __ ] week i sit there
and look at some dumb [ __ ] bring
something on a plane and i gotta ask
myself is it that important to bring a
skateboard you dumb [ __ ] so it's
time for me to bring my [ __ ]
ukulele you think i'm kidding you i'll
get like a little ukulele with a little
what do you call them a big nose yeah
yeah in the old days i'll [ __ ] blast
that [ __ ] hotel room from six to six
i know it i have a an addictive
personality and it's something i've
always wanted to do
once i got the head to do it
it's gonna scare me i'm gonna get
enthralled with it and next you know i'm
gonna be calling dean how do you start a
band and asking stupid musician
questions and people gonna say joey
actually thinks he's a [ __ ] musician
somebody better tell him he's [ __ ] 60
fat and he ain't going to be able to
jump up and down you know [ __ ] you i
ain't what is that [ __ ] you won't are
you doing what you're telling me
that's me at 60 i'll be up there [ __ ]
you i won't do what you tell me
let me give some shout outs we'll get
rudy out of everything all right yeah
yeah we're rocking you're beautiful
[ __ ]
howell i got the cancer bracelet i'm
going to put it on over the 12 days of
christmas
bob and beckin olivia linlages
la lingas i love you [ __ ] thank
you for the bruce lee book thank you for
the present for my daughter thank you
for these presents yeah
they gave me the red sox
oh my god those are amazing thank you
john and ann coulter you know how much i
love you [ __ ] i just met john
for coffee robert woolridge
armando salgado my main man jt always
got my back
chris caldwell dante gazzini
and podcast quotes i love you
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
what's up lisa how you feeling today i
don't know what you gave me but it's
strong enough to take amy when it's
strong as [ __ ] you know what i gave you
i gave you the same [ __ ] they gave out
though the other night
that [ __ ]
that was just some good advice those are
great fights those are great fights man
damien maya blew my mind oh please i
don't think he wanted to submit him i
was just watching the [ __ ] with him a
little bit oh my god so i was talk did i
tell him the podcast when i did the
other my creepy addictive personality
yeah i was telling you before the fight
then i went with jim norton after the
rogue and showing that gamble yeah let's
go to the casino real quick let me go
see what the lines are in the fights and
between you and me i told joe rogan i'm
betting a thousand ronaldo a thousand on
weidman and a thousand on the cube in
romero oh you were lost oh i would have
lost everything romero barely won the
cuban barely [ __ ] one that little
cheap [ __ ] you see him holding
the fence
and i walked over and i looked at
everything and again like my the rest of
the things in my life i became a [ __ ]
i was like i'm not [ __ ] bet nothing
and i go [ __ ] yeah why do you come to
vegas joe you don't drink you don't get
your dick sucked you don't play wheel of
fortune you do nothing you come you
perform and you eat something and you
leave go do something with your life go
at least had some fun so i went over and
i put a hundred dollars on outdoor bowl
when i'm standing on the board i go oh
[ __ ]
there's a bet for under three rounds and
i put 50 bucks on that 60 bucks what the
[ __ ] i had in my pocket 50 bucks i went
back to my room and i'm like wait a
second
that's the bed of the year and i don't
even [ __ ] gamble yeah this i can't
lose i can't lose this fight's gonna end
under three rounds
i called my wife i woke her up out of a
deep sleep and i go do me a favor
put 800 bucks on my books
what are you doing i'm gonna bet [ __ ] i
gotta bet she's like joey what the [ __ ]
you did not call your wife put 800 on my
books yes i did i don't have like 300 on
there i gotta put 800 on my [ __ ]
books
and i got up at five i really when i
called to get the wake-up call it was
the mandarin hotel
these [ __ ] said do you want a
pot of coffee mr
diaz i said you know what bring the pot
and leave them in the valet box at 4 45.
i go you guys got breakfast too they go
yeah we do i go listen why [ __ ] around
let's put the order in right now
let me get two eggs a little fruit some
wheat toast butter some juice
and uh no [ __ ] potatoes give me a
fruit because i don't want to really
wheat toast whatever
bro i got up before the alarm went off
i ate it i [ __ ] i was already packed
all i had to pack was my sleep apnea
machine
i went downstairs and i got a cab for
the mgm grand and i bet the rest of the
[ __ ] 950 so i bet i'll go for a
hundred and i never tell this [ __ ] even
lee i didn't tell him what i bet yeah i
bet not a thousand bucks on the fight
within under the third round
and i went home
and i knew it was gonna win i was more
you know i sat there going jesus i could
have
and i had a great time and i told my
wife because what'd you do how'd you end
up making out i gave it a ticket i said
mail it in [ __ ]
merry christmas [ __ ]
she just looked at me like joey you're
[ __ ] up it's yours i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't want the money i was just
proving a [ __ ] boy yeah i never
gambled dog i go to vegas ask lee for
three days i don't do nothing rude
me or whatever
the only thing i do is smoke
e-cigarettes because you don't do
nothing no more how long can we stand
there rudy it used to be in the old days
we got at least put a coca-cola a diet
coke and put a cherry in it or a lime
and lie to people tell them we've got a
rum and coke yeah now we don't even do
that it was pepsi and uh condensed milk
yeah pepsi no no you really weren't milk
oh yeah we were talking about cuban
eating habits yeah and how cubans could
be 400 pounds if you let them because
when you're a kid you dip cubans get
bread yeah and they put butter on it and
then they put in a toaster this way and
they slam but before you slam the bread
down you take the paint brush filled
with butter and you put it on top of the
bread you watch this lee so you take the
bread you cut it lee then you italian
bread like cuban italian bread you put
the butter in the middle you close it
and you put it on the thing you put
butter on the thing butter on top of the
bread and you slam it then you get a
press at your house
if you don't have a press in your cube
and you're slipping okay that's like a
jew without a yarmulke and a secret
secret secret bank account every jew has
a secret secret secret bank account what
do you got in the bank look let's go to
the atm machine i'm telling you i only
got 90 come on show me the real [ __ ]
account here show me the real one under
your grandmother's maiden name
you gotta have a press then your mother
makes you a big bowl of coffee it's not
a cup like these [ __ ] americans
let's go drink a cup
give me a vent day what [ __ ] vent day
cubans drink a ball of coffee that [ __ ]
that'll kill a mule top ramen and they
put [ __ ] whole milk in that
[ __ ] with a tub of sugar then
they wait for the toast to come out you
take the toast out lee and you cut it
across the middle so instead of two
pieces you have four pieces now and you
take that [ __ ] and you dip it in
the milk and coffee that's cuban that's
cuban savagery oh
that's cuban savagery that's after the
egg with the [ __ ] egg on that's after
the steak with the egg on top of it over
the white rice and you slice the egg
yolk and the egg yolk covers the egg and
the white rice it's called
how are you
you understand me if i want to if
anybody's skinny here and they really
want to get fat contact me i'll give you
what's called the cuban diet and then
before you go to sleep cubans do
something for the late night like when i
first came from cuba
i was always under the impression this
is how stupid your uncle joey is that
chocolate was only to be eaten at night
because the way i looked at it said
chocolate late
you know how late look so in my cuban
mind
late meant you ate chocolate at night
chocolate chocolate
you have to eat that at night what the
[ __ ]
cuba said no we don't eat chocolate
tonight we got something better for you
go get a can of vatuva mater
matervas made from what root root mate
and it's delicious it's sweet you take
three inches of condensed milk
you put aluminum foil to cover it that's
the old cuban way that's before the lid
you just get aluminum foil and you pour
that
this is what you do you would put the
condensed milk in the glass and walk
away
and it would just drip little by little
it's like when you [ __ ] 18 times that
last nut it just drips out of your nut
and just falls on your foot
it was just like that lee
and you take three fingers and you put
them a turban then you stir that
[ __ ] up and if you're real cuban
you get cuban crackers and you put
butter on them
and you eat the [ __ ] cuban crackers
with the butter or a medium which is
named after midnight midnight midnight
sandwich because you had that at
midnight because if if you went to sleep
without food you could starve to death
in your sleep because you're not eating
for eight hours oh i should have been
cute
wow now the media noche and the cuban
sandwich are different what is the
difference uh it's the pork and and the
and the pickle and the pickle the pickle
yeah that's the millionaire because the
pickle might give you nightmares or
dragons and cuban people chasing you
down yeah yeah yeah i mean what's up
you got ham and pork and pork
you really really want to get fat like
if you're a skinny guy and you want to
lift weights seriously and get 30 pounds
i got the recipe for you yeah yeah you
know i talked about the steak one like
would you have that for breakfast bro
when i was really dingy and skinny at
one time my mom would sit there once the
emulsive of god didn't work
because i was raised on emulsive of god
my mother thought that the moses of god
was the cure all be all you know
it's like a hot dog for fish the fins
the eyeballs
the guts the stomach it's like you fill
the fish they blend that up with milk
and then you take it the teaspoon of the
morning let me explain something to you
oh if every man over 50 takes emulsif of
card there'll be more [ __ ] people
being born than ever before just bone or
sick bro and most of the car when you're
six gives you hot ons
you can't even [ __ ] rest and watch
popeye you just sit there with your
mouth open
like you're doing two pounds of heroin
and cough cuban viagra emotive of god my
mom would sit there and [ __ ] stare at
me and go you're not going to school do
you have this and i'll beat you
and you had to [ __ ] take it and drink
orange juice it got to the point where
my mom would just pour it into the
orange just like vodka stir it and give
it to me
but then after that you gotta eat a
steak over
you know
well if you put a scoop of white rice
guess
flat over a thing and then they put a
[ __ ] steak a thin uh palomia that
means they butterfly yeah and you get
like an eight ounce steak and then they
put a fried egg over that and it's not
fried in granola oil
or no coconut oil it's as far as [ __ ]
butter jack and lard and lard man
that sits by the window it's big fat
like it's hard as [ __ ] concrete
and they cut into it and they throw a
chunk on the frying pan and it [ __ ]
sizzles up again and you take that egg
when it sizzles on the steak and that's
when you cut the yolk and you make the
yolk go on the right rice has anybody
ever eaten
egg and white rice oh yeah i know we
have yeah and the back of your mind is
[ __ ] disgusting i've eaten it don't
get me wrong
sounds amazing but would you [ __ ]
stop lee but if you're one if you're
skinny you lift weights yeah and you eat
one of those every day two yolks over a
[ __ ] steak
and white rice
whoop the possibilities are endless
what's that one you like it's like meat
with a sausage in the middle
boliche
and you tie cuban pot roast with a
chorizo in the middle
and you tie that [ __ ] steak up around
the chorizo and the chorizo bleeds into
the steak and then you cut it and it
falls over
jesus christ you see the chorizo looking
at you just there and you take the white
rice and you put it to the side and you
put some black beans and rice you get a
few fried bananas you cut those up
that's a breakfast of champions
you test positive for everything on that
[ __ ] and don't forget noche wayne are
having the the the uh the whole peg on
the table head and everything wow yeah
wow yeah really you don't need anything
no no all right no no
no so really you don't even know what
he's done i'm done with the porsche
listen bro yeah there's cubans that
after 40 they they substitute turkey
meat because the meat becomes too much
the amount of food they eat
the
you know
i miss my mother it's been 30-something
years and i rudy knows a cuban mom i
miss my mother but i gotta tell you it's
a confession i never said before on
another forum
my mother took her [ __ ] pork so
seriously
that they were snot in my house in the
23rd you stayed up all night just
marinating the pork your family would
come over
and like the grandma and grandpa would
go to sleep but the 40 year olds would
get aluminum four and they'd put at the
table and have coke rocks in it and
they'd sit there all night doing little
bumps drinking dew is on the rocks my
mother and her little crazy [ __ ]
girlfriends
and they'd have a pig and they'd
marinate that pig all night orange juice
and garlic and you got to rub it in
there there was like a ceremony bro wow
it's like a ceremony yeah it's like a
it's a family thing we're going to get
together and drink but at the same time
we're cooking and then and you'd wake up
and hate and the house would smell
like heaven when you wake up at a cuban
house on the 24th of december
it's heaven that [ __ ] pork you know i
just took my wife back for cuban food my
wife's in my [ __ ] farm in tennessee
she bit into the cholesterol and the
first thing she said to me she goes i
get it
she goes they they [ __ ] this is what
this is love well it's the emojo
i don't think you can get those oranges
here which is a sour orange
it's like a mandarin orange or something
and it's it's a whole different flavor
it's like in between a grapefruit and an
orange you know it's like sour
garlic and
everything else that goes into it moho
yeah they would stay up all night
preparing it and then at eight in the
morning that's when they throw it in the
oven so they would do an all-nighter is
it a shaped or roasted
yeah december 24th early in the morning
you hear the the the pig squealing you
know like because it's getting killed
but as a kid growing up like that in my
culture that was like wow we're gonna
eat good tonight yeah
and you know which now to me is a
horrific you know uh thought yeah but uh
yeah and then you just start pulling up
pieces of the skin the ears
and the skin comes next to the [ __ ]
did you ever roast a pig in like your
house in jersey all the time
my mother listen december in a cuban
house is 20 pounds and it starts
december 3rd
there's a cuban holiday then wednesday
morning
it's thursday night and then san lazado
is the 16th that's another big one and
then the 24th dogs [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] bigger
than christmas it is christmas it's
cuban christmas then they celebrate the
7th of january yeah what is that that's
when the the wise kings show up with a
grandma
and they give you an envelope you get
cash on that day
yeah
which is actually the 12th day of
christmas
it is yeah rudy
you don't eat meat anymore right i i eat
meat but not pork what kind of diet do
you have because you look fantastic and
that's vitamins vitamins and workout
exercise yeah is it is it uh is it light
weights or do you just walk and it'll
jump no no i mean i i do some weights uh
i try not to injure myself now because
of my age and yeah but one great thing
about medicare it's uh the the plan that
i had
things that i'm talking about it's
called silver fit which is like medicare
plus for like uh
20
dollars a year you just join like a
regular gym instead of like paying you
know
for 500 which in my case because i spent
so much time on the road uh we're just
like buying like a month here and a
month there but now i just paid 20 20
bucks a year and that's it i go to like
a 24 fitness place that's great yeah
and then something to look forward to
yeah the government pays the other half
well you already been paying you know
they have all these years that's been
coming out of your salary yeah social
security yeah exactly yeah wow yeah
really god bless you man i bless you too
it's really now yeah it's hard to
believe that i was watching you
at the palladium 30 something years ago
and here we are in north hollywood it's
so weird right it's like a dream come
true you're the sweetest guy in the
world and here you are 65 looking
beautiful
living your life who would have [ __ ]
thought we would have still been talking
about ozzie at a table he's still
[ __ ] alive you know i i don't look
any different than when it was 64. you
know you look beautiful
you look great man
i mean you're good you know i played
with him last year and this guy destroys
on stage man like
here's a funny thing this is when i knew
that i was nev uh
sometimes you wonder as a musician like
i never got to that next level you know
and then when i jammed with him
brian tischy and tracy guns
when they kicked in i was like this is
why
these guys are next level dudes you know
you know it's just like you guys you
know you guys put a lot of time into
into your art you know i mean it just
don't happen back then you got to take
some time and develop your your act and
and your your your material
you know your relationship with the
audience it's the same thing for us you
know just put time into it yeah but the
way you played the bass i could feel it
over there you know just the attack and
and he was so into it well it's the same
way when i saw your performance you know
i got it yeah and i became an instant
fan that's because you know you have
that connection with the audience it's
the same thing you have a very rock and
roll connection you know yeah you know
with the audience it's like it's like a
rock musician you know and coco here
he's just freaking amazing every time i
watch
anything with you on youtube you're
relentless and fearless
i know it's not totally it's like you're
on on on on it's unbelievable i've
learned so much watching him at the
store man yeah he's like an inva
monstein level
whenever i tell a cuban story on those
ari things i always think of you i
always think in the back of my mind i
think of everybody who's cuban that i
know because
we grew up different ways and everybody
there's still one basis like the faith
part you know
and i did this last ari thing which will
be out this year and i talked about when
i did santo you know as a little kid and
i
liked it i i really enjoyed i i'm a
catholic bro i'm a catholic uh
just i don't know we come from a
catholic country cuba's a catholic
country and i was raised a catholic and
i still have my beliefs
in different ways but i had a godmother
growing up who i loved dearly you know
she was a cuban lady you know i always
talk about pre-revolutionary cubans
are the toughest people you don't want
to [ __ ] with them at any level
pre-revolutionary cubans they're the
ones that built miami they're the ones
that have to deal with those jews
the first time they they're smooth
they're [ __ ] but they're
strong-willed pre-revolutionary cubans
put ideas in your head they dealt with
[ __ ] you know everybody talks about
fidel batista was no walk in the [ __ ]
park either
but there's something about
pre-revolutionary cubans and she was
everything to me and she used to always
tell me growing up put a box away
and put your trophies in there and when
she put she made me put my locker hair
in there and she made me put my brass
shoes in there she made me put newspaper
clippings and she'd go once a week i
want you to go sit with that [ __ ] box
it was brilliant
and i go why do you [ __ ] make me sit
with this box because no matter what
happens in your life i want you to
remember that who the [ __ ] you are and
where you came from
and i would put [ __ ] in there when my
mother died she goes make sure you take
that box with you and you always look at
that [ __ ] box once a week because i
don't want this experience to
and she like knew my mother was gonna
die that's why she'd make me [ __ ] get
that box every day and look at the box
and i [ __ ] put the box at my friend's
house and i ended up robbing him years
later he was a coke dealer i left the
box
and when i left new york in 85 i bumped
in and she goes where's the box
and i didn't want to tell her like oh it
said martin the [ __ ] my thing marico
that was his name
and i go you know the box is at his
house and she goes i'll [ __ ] get it
back whatever i didn't tell him i robbed
martin
and i'd lost my box you know through all
those years i lost that box at pictures
of my mother and pictures of my real
father and just little things in there
my my son so i had a bunch of [ __ ] in
there
and i made a [ __ ] interview for some
religious company in england and they
put the video on and do you know i got
my box back
lady called me from miami in 2014. no we
have your box
uh my godmother's grandson has the box
what i flew to miami i booked the gig i
got the [ __ ] box 34 years later
i got my [ __ ] soul back somebody had
that box still and my life changed and
she brought the box
from new york city 148th street
to miami on a [ __ ] bus wow because
and she kept saying even when i die
i know that kid he's going to come back
here for that [ __ ] box she goes leave
that the kid all his life grew up he's
amanda he works at miami international
airport yeah he goes since i was a kid i
go grandma whose box is that that's
cocos one day he's coming back for that
box even after i'm dead i know that kid
he's gonna come back for that box wow
[ __ ] 2015 i got the box next to my
[ __ ] bed i told that story and i
thought about you because we lose
ourselves in our lives man i lost myself
for a [ __ ] long time
and you know what some people sell their
soul they never got it back though i
sold myself i got it back yeah a lot of
people don't get their [ __ ] soul back
and i know some people will listen to
that story i don't know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about
i know rudy would think of that story
and go jesus [ __ ] christ
because there's a certain faith you grew
up as cuban i've always had that faith
i've always had that belief you know
what i'm saying so yeah i'm happy you
came out rudy and i'm sorry we only got
you
a couple potatoes [ __ ] porto's they
got smarter they made them yeah
you know they're [ __ ] communists
you know what frustration is when you
want to read about the topics that
interest you most and you have to
mentally search for the content of the
internet
you know uh for those of us who want
premium content don't have time to waste
on finding it there's a new company
called texture the best way to read all
your favorite magazines magazines
anytime anywhere
texture is the app that gives you an all
access pass to the world's best
magazines right on your phone or tablet
browse hundreds of magazines and cherry
pick the articles that interest you the
most
the texture editorial team recommends
stories for you daily plus their curated
collections let you dive into deeper
into the topics do me a favor sign up
for texture right now in mere seconds
you're going to gain insider access to
the very best reads plus exclusive
content with full access to the top
magazines across the board of every
interest i mean from lulu to in style to
hot rod to oprah to 17 the national
geographic rolling stone the new yorker
us weekly us weekly whatever i'm sorry
team vogue the hollywood reporter they
got everything here's the best part
texas offering my listeners a free trial
right now when you go to texture.com
joey even better get texture as a gift
between now and december 31st think
about that you'll gain unrestricted
access to the world's best magazines
from back issues to the one on
newsstands today
order this fantastic gift for you or a
loved one before december 31st try
texture for free right now when you go
to texture.com
joey again
texture app is the easiest way to remain
culturally curious with the top stories
and new and noteworthy sections updated
throughout the day plus you can share
your subscription with the whole family
you can download articles and whole
issues for online reading go to
texture.com right now slash joey what do
you think about that [ __ ] i
actually like that i like that this is
not bad i still love magazines you
download the articles before you go on a
plane you can read the certain ones and
rollins i mean how many [ __ ]
magazines you really read three or four
yeah rolling stone us weekly whatever
the [ __ ] as always on it my main people
you know i think that you're on this
stuff because you look beautiful on it
number one product is alpha brain it's a
complete earth-grown neutrality
ireland is like a
it just it's tough to describe honor is
a company that makes supplements for you
and what they do is that they have
shrimp tag sport and immunes like if i
fly a lot like i flew i took shroom tech
immune i didn't get sick my wife got
sick
okay uh shroom tech support gives you
more endurance it has quadricep um uh
mushrooms in them and they just give you
more oxygen is it a multivitamin and not
really they have multivitamins other
things they have tea oil they have
testosterone boosters anyway go to
hunter.com right now slash joey and get
10 off your first dose church what is it
it's honest.com you use codeword church
on it.com with the codeword church and
get 10 off your first order also you get
on the stay on it program and they
deliver it right to your house on a
weekly [ __ ] basis okay on it's
got some great stuff when i fly i take
the turn around 160 which is this with a
bunch of other stuff 180 i'm sorry it
has the same 360. yeah and hit e6
the best in hit vapor cigarettes okay
they they're tremendous zero eight 16
and 24 milligrams and a cigar that's
what they got usually go for 20 bucks a
piece because you're friends with me you
get it for 10 bucks a piece i got a
special five for 50 offer
go to hittiesticks.com and press in
joey's church boom
and get five for 50. and that's it all
right oh i want to prompt my uh punch
line hold on one second texture.com
right now what is it slash joey slash
texture dot com slash joey on it
dot com slash joey
what is it
good
it's on it code word church all right
hit these things now i need a big
favorite from you guys i don't think no
[ __ ] favor september 28th 29th my
buddies dean delray's going to be at the
san francisco punchline or at cops yeah
punchline at the putz line downtown
listen if you don't go to this show
shoot yourself right [ __ ] now okay
you know when we go to san francisco how
we do it please go over and see him
tickets are available where at
punchline.com slap slash joey nothing no
okay [ __ ] it
punchline.com delray
when do you start your little thing
again my brother
um it starts at the beginning of the
year with namm show and then it goes to
i'm doing a uh axes and anchors cruise
it's a rock and roll cruise who's on
that one i'm doing uh some shows with
tracy we're you know gonzo our band and
then uh uh uh
randy rhodes remember and all of that so
a bunch of guys zach wilde and inve and
and just a bumble foot a bunch of yeah
it's incredible yeah yeah it's it's it's
in a boat and where's the cruise go to
uh
key west and the bahamas the caribbean
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah for four days so
there's absolutely the girlfriend with
you yeah give me your live reports look
at them you should yeah
total rock and roll cruise and then
after that i i'm off to europe and uh
in russia with gunzo no no with
something else oh wow yeah yeah cool
yeah good to have you here i love you
thanks you too love you
rudy has just been an unbelievable
friend and so have you so it's just it's
just amazing i would podcast with you
every day what about lee you don't like
lena yeah i love lee
i love lee lee just doesn't text me late
at night like you you know he doesn't
check up on me
he's got to start checking up on people
i love you guys we'll be back tomorrow
uh thank rudy sarso also my man dean
delray and the flying jew for coming on
we'll be back tomorrow in san diego
thursday night second show got added
so go do your [ __ ] thing see you
thursday i love you guys stay black
you gotta go to the bathroom